we're continuing to follow as we
continue to get closer and closer to the
2022 midterms different races primaries
elections and campaigns that are going
on one that's really important is the
georgia gubernatorial race georgia
played such an outsized role in the 2020
election due to the focus on it by those
falsely claiming that donald trump
actually won the state rather than joe
biden joe biden really won in georgia in
2020. one of the people running in
georgia for governor is a woman named
candice taylor that's k-a-n-d-i-s-s
is the spelling of candace
a very disturbed woman not only does she
seem completely clueless about every
single issue she was asked about during
a recent debate we looked at some clips
earlier this week she has a new ad that
is like nothing i have ever seen
i'm going to play it for you it's sort
of like christian dominionist fear porn
it's like a two roughly two minute video
and the entire concept is that there's a
satanic regime
which her governorship would demolish
you might notice that that has
definitely like a q anon sort of sound
to it you really have to hear and see it
and i understand that it seems like
satire i get that
it feels like a skit but it's real take
a look at take a listen to this some
might even say
they had to get our permission
to at least tell us ahead of time
even if we didn't believe them
over four billion people have been
injected
with something that took just nine
months to create
so anti-vaxx
ask yourself
why back in biblical times human
sacrifice was a form of demonic worship
we're
demons
this video also contains
a depiction of an alleged jewish ritual
sacrifice it's a really anti-semitic
thing from the nuremberg chronicle still
doing it
in present day by killing our unborn
this is anti-abortion same demons
anti-vaxx anti-semitic anti-abortion
sacrifice is the same sin it's just a
different time
this is a long shot in and of itself
running for governor against an
incumbent
why are you doing this good question we
don't
call things out and we don't acknowledge
them and we don't take authority
and take dominion over what god's given
us so dominion is an important word for
these folks i mean they are quite
literally christian dominionists and the
use of that word is very specific
then
we are no better than the evil ones that
put it up
we've watched as people have destroyed
our history and monuments and in their
place they have erected statutes to
their own gods
the new world order is here new world
order so so look i mean think of it look
at what's adding up here
anti-vaxx
anti-semitic
anti-abortion
ghost demons and satan
new world order conspiracy
and they told us it was coming
it's a battle far greater than what we
see in the natural
it is a war
between good and evil
yeah
uh so that um
this is
it it feels like us it must be a skit
who could possibly be this delusional in
this paranoid and this disconnected from
real reality but it's real and if you
look at the comments online there are
people who are genuinely unsure whether
it's real because it's so absurd
this is someone who sounds like they
need professional help if you met
someone like this and if it wasn't a
campaign ad
but it was a dinner party
and they told you that they believe the
things that this woman says she believes
in the ad
you would say delusional paranoia and
unfortunately there's a bunch of them
running in some races they're all like
this at least in the republican primary
i should say all of the choices are like
this
horrifyingly dangerous and we are
barreling
towards a disastrous 2022 midterm where
folks like this could win
think about that
we've been covering the supposed
bankruptcy of infowars conspiracy
theorist alex jones this is a very
complicated topic which involves alex
jones being the target of multiple
lawsuits
and
presumably going in the direction of him
owing people a bunch of money including
parents of the victims of sandy hook and
interspersed with this i told you a
couple of weeks ago that alex jones has
declared
bankruptcy and we and others immediately
questioned the timing of the bankruptcy
and of course the useful nature of a
bankruptcy if you're trying to avoid
paying anybody one of the great things
to do is to say you don't have any money
well now alex jones is actually bragging
about 2 million dollar donations that
they've received he says now they have
five million dollars in the bank
and uh this is something that to me
seems like it would be very interesting
to the bankruptcy trustees take a look
guess what you must have made the donor
man i don't know who they are where they
are they could be in japan could be in
the u.s could be who knows where i
appreciate them whoever they are bought
hundreds of millions of dollars of
bitcoin at a lower price
back in 2016 never spent any of them and
has now given us
a million dollars a bitcoin and you must
have upset them
whoever they are because oh sorry to the
left of the globalist they gave us a
million dollars more on saturday let me
break that for you while you sit there
and say we're covering it all up and
hiding in bank accounts and all this
crap
so
i mean you don't even need a bank
account to hide bitcoin to actually
we no longer have three million dollars
in the company
barely enough to make payroll and
operate my product we now have five
million dollars and we guess what you
must
so i'm sure this is something the
bankruptcy court would be interested in
bankruptcy trustees the trustee
overseeing the sandy hook parents case
the sandy hook families would be very
very interested in hearing about this
you know i sat next to one of alex jones
former attorneys on a flight recently i
talked about this on the bonus show or
maybe it was on a live stream i don't
think i've mentioned it on the podcast
no attorney client privilege was
breached because it was publicly known
that this lawyer represented alex jones
at one point
it was quite a conversation
and um you know alex jones on the one
hand
has
a whole area of controversy related to
what counts as free speech and that's
controversial enough and when does the
speech become
defamatory and all of these things are
kind of being legislated right now the
other side of this is this very strange
and suspicious bankruptcy and i don't
doubt for a second that the bankruptcy
isn't justifiable in some way
but the timing is just so suspect so
suspect
and now bragging about having five
million dollars now if you went to him
he would go
for us five million is borderline
bankruptcy because our payroll is so
high and our costs to produce all these
various supplements is so high i don't
even know whether the supplements are
actually some people when they do
products
they don't buy a bunch of inventory up
front they're just kind of produced and
shipped on demand drop shipping anyway
we don't know the the nature of that
business
but he would say this is just barely
enough to fund our operation it's not
like now we're flush with cash we
certainly don't have any money for the
um
sandy hook families but this all stinks
to high heaven and it continues to point
in that direction and quite frankly i
don't know what the end game is i don't
know if alex jones genuinely believes
that these uh manipulations when it
comes to the bankruptcy and having cash
and not in bitcoin donations and all of
it um
i don't know
i don't know the other thing
is uh
whether
there's
someone wrote to me and said alex jones
seems confused
about whether they got a million dollars
in bitcoin
or whether they got one bitcoin now i i
could he really be confused about that i
don't think so now if he knows the value
listen i have absolutely no idea but it
would be an extra funny thing on top of
all of the scam that's being run here if
he actually got one bitcoin and not a
million dollars in bitcoin one bitcoin
worth about 30 35 grand at this point in
time i don't know what the future of
this is but it all stinks and the
grifting and the scamming continues let
me know your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at d pacman we have a packed
friday show for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported program you can sign up for a
membership at joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code obama
that's obama
to get a discount at joinpakman.com
you'll get the bonus show you'll get the
commercial free audio stream you'll get
the commercial free video stream you'll
get priority access during viewer town
halls and on and on and on
sign up at joinpacman.com
let's hear from people in the audience
the audience is why we do this without
the audience i'm a guy with a mic and
the mic might not even work if there
were no audience we do calls via discord
you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord we are going to go first
to nico from i believe it's new haven
connecticut nico welcome
oh boy
nico from new haven
connecticut
welcome
nico you're on the air
and nico is gone
let's go next to steve from chicago
steve welcome you're on the air
hi david
um
i was just wondering um i saw your video
about the um
the decision that was leaked for the
supreme court yes and i know that
towards the end you're kind of talking
about um
next steps what could happen if this
happened
um i kind of i feel like you're usually
pretty rational i kind of felt like your
thought process was
like do you actually think that's
something realistically that would
happen
listen i i did i did a follow-up on
wednesday
where i say i'm not literally claiming
that in the next few months they're
going to try to ban interracial marriage
that's not what i'm saying what i am
saying is you don't stop with one of
your biggest victories and say now we're
satisfied we're not doing anything else
charlie kirk literally said
if you can get rid of roe v wade
anything is possible so even they are
saying it so yes i do think they're
going to try to go further i think it
might be um gay marriage i think it
could be you know
access to contraception with no co-pays
uh but yes i think they're going to try
to go further
okay i mean i i really don't i mean i'm
not saying that they wouldn't we they
want to go for anything else i just
um don't think i've really seen
much movement of like pushing for like
the getting rid of uh interracial
marriages or okay but i'm not sure steve
are you did you listen to it did you
hear what i said
yeah i i heard what you said okay
i'm also agreeing with anything's
possible but i've not seen any movement
in the last few days since the decision
leaked to try to ban interracial
marriage but there's a list of of things
which some of these conservatives are
also against and my view is they're not
going to stop with abortion but i agree
with you in the last four days
they've not said we want to ban into
racial marriage we're on absolutely the
same page steve
no i'm on the same page there i'm saying
also not even counting the past four
days
looking at
what they would like to do i don't think
that's even close to the top of
something that would be within the next
years
or any time like any relevant time you
think they
would you agree that they would gladly
try to get rid of uh
no co-payment access to contraception as
part of obamacare you think that's
something they would want to get rid of
uh i think that would be definitely i
don't
i don't think that's a top list but i
think it's definitely more realistic
than them being like let's get rid of
gay marriage okay i think i think many
of them would love to get rid of gay
marriage but listen let's just give it
time and then we'll we'll see but i
don't think this is the end let's i'll
just put it that way
okay i i was i just kind of wanted
clarification because i just i maybe i
missed your follow-up it kind of just
sounded that you like thought like
literally next step would you get rid of
like gay marriage and stuff like that
and
didn't seem like there's been any like
major push for that
right uh yeah i gave a list of you know
a half dozen things let's see what they
do next
all right thank you all right there's
steve from chicago
uh why don't we go next to
uh oh this is interesting let's go to
juan
from my birth city of buenos aires
argentina juan welcome
hey david
um
so you might know that uh abortion was
legalized in argentina last year i
didn't know that a big
a big part of that movement was like the
green bandana
um
being in buenos aires i saw that
everywhere and i think that had like a
big psychological effect like that the
green bandana
like public displays greatly outnumbered
like the blue bandanna pro-lifer
public displays do you think the
americans should adopt a symbol
like that for their um protests
absolutely i mean i don't think it's the
only thing that should be done by but
why not we know those types of things
work and are effective and you know in a
sense it's a version of the lawn sign
like you see a lot of lawn signs for a
candidate it doesn't mean they're
necessarily going to win but i do think
people are more
uh invigorated in a sense behind uh
political ideas when it looks like
there's a community of support so sure i
would be fine with something like that i
think it would be great
totally
awesome so what's going on down are you
are you from argentina
no i'm from uh venezuela actually i i
immigrated here in 2018 and i i really
love argentina man the and the cities
really treated me well are with
empanadas are you for or against raisins
in the empanada
i'm very against raisins really
the venezuelan empanada is actually
quite different from the uh
from the argentina i i i'm a little
biased but i think ours are better david
but aren't venezuelan empanadas
typically fried
yeah oh my god
get get me away from that what if it's
not oven baked put it in the trash one
god
all right thank you for the call though
i appreciate it i appreciate it no
problem okay there is juan from
venezuela now in argentina what a
beautiful phone call
let's go next to bob from colorado bob
welcome
hey dave thanks for taking my call
pleasure
so um just about like everybody else i'm
gonna ask about the abortion thing okay
um do you think this could maybe be
well let me let me let me uh tell you
where i'm coming from okay so
i know you mentioned a couple times that
you think maybe
um many republicans
don't want to ban abortion or overturn
roe v wade because of such an important
fundraising issue yes
do you think this could be
with everything going on with roe v wade
could be like a long-term loss for them
because they lose such an important
uh political wedge issue right so i
think it is possible that in the long
term it will give them it will take away
a tool for the right to raise money but
remember that in the short run
just about every blue state and many red
states still allow abortion so for the
next however many years they'll just
shift to saying okay
we got what we needed at the supreme
court now we have to go state by state
to ban abortion so they'll just move the
the goal so i think they'll have plenty
of uh cannon fodder or no i guess what
would be the right term they'll have
plenty of gun powder
for many years at this point
okay and do you do you think it'll
become um kind of a rallying issue for
the left maybe get people more motivated
to vote that's my hope and i mentioned
this on monday my hope is that
absolutely or tuesday um my hope is that
yes if there's anything that can save
the midterms maybe it will be this
and kind of because i know one of the
issues with the left is uh we have
really low turnout and kind of there's
kind of a belief among many people that
voting doesn't matter everybody's the
same oh it matters huh i mean let's
think back to 2016 now
exactly yeah so hopefully this will be
this will kind of light the fire under
everybody and make everybody wake up and
realize holy crap that's my hope i mean
listen this is a disaster but if there
is to be any silver lining
that would potentially be it and we'll
know within a few months if that happens
alrighty thank you for taking my call
david thank you for the call there's bob
a very very important issue
let's go next to casey from kansas casey
welcome
howdy
i'm assuming everybody's already asked
abortion questions there have been a
number of them
but mine is just more about the
the democrats response to this
uh do you fear that the moderate
democrats will be
too weak
to fight for abortion rights in this
case
um yeah i mean to some degree i think i
i haven't paid to be perfectly frank i
haven't paid much attention to the
moderate democrat response so far but it
wouldn't surprise me to see moderate
democrats pay i mean listen uh uh the
they can they can probably sort of not
anger anybody too much to jeopardize
their positions by saying
i am for choice but want to leave it up
to the states that's the kind of cop-out
centrist uh statement they can make
okay and just one more thing do you
think that the
the democrats response to the extremist
supreme court has been a failure until
now
the way that they have like
not allowed rhetoric about uh
how dangerous the supreme court is with
the extremists in it and
completely not allowed discussion about
packing the courts or anything i would
say yes but it's even bigger than that
it's even back to 2016 not enough
democrats and people on the left saying
this is exactly what might happen if
trump beats hillary i was saying it and
i'm not patting myself on the back
because there were others saying it as
well but jimmy dore and sam cedar uh i
don't remember sam sam taking that
position i remember dorae taking it he
had he had a debate with jimmy dore oh
right and sam i think was in agreement
with me right yeah yeah yeah no it's uh
this has been a problem for a while and
you're identifying one element of the
problem but it's an even bigger problem
okay okay well thanks for taking my
question david my pleasure thank you so
much for the call i appreciate that
let's go next to miguel from the country
of peru miguel bienvenido
how are you doing i'm doing well now
you're not on a
on an uh a speaker phone are you you
would never do that
i would never do it okay i have
headphones on right now beautiful
um great i love the conversations about
empanadas i think peru has a lot to
contribute to that conversation
but
um i am pro reason but i will ask the
more substantive question um before we
talk about that please
um
so about inflation um it's a big issue
not only in the u.s but all over the
world and i've had a lot of
conversations about if cpi or percentage
change of cpi which is how we measure
inflation is really the best way to
reflect
the increase of of uh cost of living
especially between different uh socio
demographic groups so my question to you
would be
is there a better way or
anything that has been proposed to
understand
the cost uh the increase in cost of
living in different social demographic
groups
yeah i mean you're absolutely correct
that cpi meaning the consumer price
index which is often how we look at
inflation
does not capture
every situation and every population
equally
if i understand correctly it's mostly
urban centers and they're looking at
food and beverages housing apparel
transportation medical care recreation
you know it's a it's a bunch of
different things uh you're completely
right it's not perfect and it doesn't
capture uh maybe at low middle and
higher incomes what the change has been
and of course the other thing to
remember is that for lower incomes a
five percent increase is much more
meaningful than a five per cent increase
at higher incomes so no metric is
perfect and i i mean i think the the
issue would be
okay so
let's propose something else and i'm not
sure what that would be
but um it's not a perfect metric
agreed agreed um i have a quick another
question um i'm half jewish but i'm not
um very connected with with that part of
my heritage um
what would be some jewish foods
and in particular um
are jewish foods in the u.s mostly
eastern european because i kind of feel
like that's kind of what's going on when
i eat jewish food in the u.s um is there
american jewish food versus
eastern european jewish food versus
middle eastern jewish food what does
that look like i don't i can't say too
much about american jewish food but
basically when people are talking about
so-called jewish food you've got the
eastern european stuff which has a lot
of overlap with russian and ukrainian
and polish food as well
and then you have what we would consider
more the israeli foods which have a lot
of overlap with other middle eastern
countries so you know in your eastern
european uh kind of area you've got your
matzo ball soup of course you've got
pastrami on rye with mustard uh you have
kanishas you you know you have kind of
like that world chocolate babka things
like this on your middle eastern more
israeli israeli-type mediterranean side
there's a lot of overlap with other
middle eastern countries even a little
bit with places like greece etc and so
there you're talking about falafel or
falafel as some like to say
hummus stuff like that um i don't know
about like american jewish food i think
it's just a kind of either of the two
things i just mentioned correct i was
just thinking about pastrami sandwiches
when i like the
jewish diner kind of thing yeah i guess
that is more american so so i guess i'll
go back like the idea of brisket is more
of an eastern european thing because it
used to be really cheap and you you know
it wasn't very good and you had to cook
it all day for it to be remotely tender
now brisket is is is very hip but i
think if you talk about you know places
like cats deli in new york that would be
more the americanized eastern european
jewish food
all right pleasure
all right my pleasure there is miguel
from peru
very powerful declarations that he made
about food let's take a very quick break
if you're holding we're coming right
back to the phone so don't go anywhere
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow let's go right back and
hear from some members of the audience
we do these calls via discord you can
find our discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to snake from moscow
russia this should be interesting snake
what's going on
snake from moscow russia please unmute
and last chance for snake from moscow
russia
too bad too bad that would have been
interesting let's go next to uh let's go
to rich from illinois rich welcome
hi david hello
um so i was the top mod of the donald on
reddit for years until just before it
was banned and with elon buying twitter
do you think that there will be a
general shift in policy
for the uh the tech places um towards
allowing things
like medical misinformation such as
ivermectin and what
vice's motherboard did yesterday with uh
tweeting out the misoprostol for
abortion pills
i wha what i didn't see the bite what's
the vice thing tell me about that
yeah so they uh tweeted out from their
motherboard account that misoprostol
which is a horse medicine
uh to treat ulcers for horses
can be used for
abortion pills oh i see that now yeah uh
okay so let's go step by step first i uh
i actually discussed this with coleman
hughes in an already recorded but not
yet released podcast episode with him i
actually don't think that elon musk
taking over twitter if it happens
remember it's still not been approved
and i think it may not be but we'll wait
and see
i don't think it's going to do anything
mind-blowing on on twitter per se i
think maybe some people will be unbanned
maybe not i don't know that he is widely
going to be involved in content
moderation so
i'm kind of i'm not making any big
judgments about what's going to change
on twitter let's first wait and see if
the the buyout actually happens and then
we'll kind of think about that part
um in terms of uh i mean listen i don't
know much about this misoprostol thing
but
i i also don't know whether this is an
approved off-label use or not i don't
know anything about it but let me just
say right now
all of this stuff should be subject to
the same scrutiny whether it's being
promoted by left or right i i think it
all should be subjected to the exact
same terms of service
okay
that's good now let me ask you so you
were you were a top moderator on the
donald which was widely considered one
of the most toxic enclaves of the
internet until it was banned are you a
trump guy
i am wow and so and and now what do you
think about like do you believe
ivermectin works to treat covid
i i don't know because i'm not a doctor
okay
how would you determine do you do you
think advil works for headaches
i do and why do you think that not being
a doctor
so it does for some people it does for
it doesn't for others ibuprofen works
for others better than advil does or
or you know other things
are the same thing
yeah yeah
aspirin that's what i mean okay but so
why do you not being a doctor why do you
feel so strongly about your knowledge of
ibuprofen and not ivermectic no no yeah
that wasn't the uh the kind of gist of
what i was trying to get at um the fact
that people were getting banned for
mentioning
off-label use of ivermectin which is
approved drug for humans
but it's not even covered you agree that
with that right
all right well i don't know but like i
said i'm not a doctor so i don't pretend
to wait a second hold on a second see
the problem is
whenever i ask you a direct question you
say i don't know because i'm not a
doctor but you just asserted you you do
know that ivermectin is quote approved
for humans but isn't how do you know
that without being a doctor well i know
that ivermectin is approved for humans
because that that is actually um
documented
instead of saying i don't know i'm not a
doctor you would just say i don't know
okay yeah so if i were to assert to you
that the way we figure out if a
medication works for a condition is to
do a randomized controlled trial would
you agree that that's a good way to
figure out whether a medication works
i do believe in science so i would agree
100 with that beautiful and
if i told you that there were two
randomized controlled trials which
looked at ivermectin for covid and
neither showed that it did anything
would that be compelling if you were to
see those studies i know you haven't
seen them but given that you've accepted
the randomized control trial if
randomized controlled trials said it
doesn't work for kovid would that
satisfy you
oh of course it would okay good all
right well those studies exist check out
my clips on them okay
okay all right uh you still like trump
well i was going to say this uh myso
pro so thing is being out there and and
they are being banned for it even though
it's not approved for use for on humans
they are not being banned you're saying
no yeah yeah they didn't yeah listen
this is the first i heard about it so i
i'm not trying to cop out like it
these claims should all be managed in
the same way but in terms of terms of
service you know we have to have the
same rules no matter whether it's
hydroxy or misoprostol or whatever i
just don't know anything about
misoprostol right now so i can't say
okay fair yep all right thanks so much
for the call i appreciate it yeah thanks
for taking no problem
all right see guys look at that what a
conversation
we were able to do it
uh let's hear from a couple of other
people
um just remember that putting
parentheses in front of your nickname on
discord to get to the top of the list
guarantees you will not speak to me
because that it's just it's just a trick
okay people are like oh it's
alphabetical i'll start with parentheses
and then i'll be at the top i don't even
look at those so that's a good way to to
not get on let's go to chris from
massachusetts chris welcome
hey david
hello
um i don't have much for you today i
guess um
uh have you have any other callers
talked about the roe v wade decision
only all of them
only all of them what about the uh the
leak
yeah well i mean listen uh the leak
summer saying is the most serious thing
that's ever happened worse than the
trump riots the fact that this leaked
three weeks early it's like pearl harbor
yeah i mean uh that in my opinion is
probably one of like i don't know the
lesser consequential factors of this
whole kind of i agree i think that's
unfolding right it is a kind of one
thing though is i i've heard people
saying online that you know oh the
leaker is this patriot
and uh we don't really know
why this content was leaked i agree so i
would i would be hesitant to
you know kind of go like take that line
so early because you know there's a
compelling
something that i find compelling is the
idea that you know this was leaked
earlier than the normal uh supreme court
summer
uh publishing of these decisions yeah to
get it into the media cycle
earlier than it would be and farther
away from the midterms so that i can run
through the media cycle uh maybe folks
will forget about it um
before the midterms happen it's very
speculative it's very i mean listen you
could say
oh no they leaked it the day
that the primaries started to have the
maximum effect or you could say what
you're saying which is if you wait it
has more of an effect so by leaking it
instead of waiting until the end of june
now voters can have it in mind for all
of the primaries in may and june i think
you can make the argument either way we
just don't know for me it's like we
found out three weeks earlier that's
that's it it's really not a big part of
the story for me
do you think there's any merit in like
the idea that you know
these leaks you know if they were to
happen again in the future would
influence you know the supreme court
justices and their decisions
i i really don't because i mean i don't
know they're appointed for life and they
have great security it's just hard for
me to imagine that
yeah because it seems like
because of the fact they were appointed
for life i mean how much is public
opinion right uh really influence their
decisions i agree completely yeah i just
i just don't see it
all right thanks david all right my
pleasure there's chris from
massachusetts with some relevant
elements for today's show i'm told snake
from moscow has fixed their mic let's
try it once more snake please are you
with us from moscow
hi can you hear me now yes snake welcome
hi thank you for uh taking my call uh i
guess my question would be a lot more
theoretical rather than pertaining to
particular issues but there is a debate
among liberal russian elites or general
anti-war population on the purpose and
value of non-violent protests when
russia has engaged in an attempt to
destroy ukrainian statehood and the
anti-war protests which are peaceful
usually manifest themselves as graffiti
is writing on cash etc trying to
distribute anti-war messaging without
getting into any type of violent or
physical altercation with anybody or
anything
so my question you know is do you think
there is any value or purpose in
non-violent measures in a time which is
essentially war enacted by our
government against other people this is
a really great question because at some
point you know all of us who as a
principal are against violence
sometimes we get to a point where we say
well we're trying to protest horribly
violent acts like the invasion
of ukraine
with signs and
writing on dollar bills and it just
doesn't if i'm hearing you correctly
snake you're saying it does is it really
going to achieve anything is it is it is
it enough
that is the sense that's this is nothing
in comparison to state propaganda and
therefore is useless and
doesn't need to exist yeah i mean i i am
i am
sympathetic to that question and where i
come down is and and maybe i'm naive or
idealistic
i just don't know that
the random people on the street getting
violent is actually going to have the
effect on the policy
that maybe we would like it to compared
to
crippling sanctions
uh um
government saying
we are not going to allow this or or
what it's it's just hard for me to
imagine it's you know to some degree
snake
it's like when these people say if the
jews had handguns world war ii wouldn't
have happened and every historian that
has looked at it says that's just not
true so i understand the instinct but i
wonder
how fac how based in reality the idea is
i just don't know
thank you and if i can my second
question is going to be slightly more
more practical
how do you think we can build bridges
between populations that are not
existing in the same reality in the
united states it seems to me like
anybody moderate versus trumpist slash
mega hat people
in russia it's the so-called vitamix who
are soviet-era ideologues versus more
younger liberal or just plain more
moderate population of russia do you
think it is even possible to build
bridges between such groups of people
who don't seem to align anywhere
so i think it's possible
here's the answer at the at the
individual level every expert i've
spoken to says the way you build those
bridges is you have to just start with
what we agree on and sometimes it's very
little but there's usually some
agreement uh do we agree that we prefer
solutions without violence yes okay
let's use that and then see where we get
to a point of disagreement this is a
long arduous time consuming process
at the mass scale level how do we
deprogram people who won't even accept
basic facts i don't have the answer to
that unfortunately
okay thank you very much for taking my
question so before you go you're calling
from russia
yeah from moscow and so
what is the would you say the general
sentiment there is that people like the
invasion of ukraine or people are
against the invasion of ukraine
uh i have to say that i will have a
certain moscow liberal bias because
that's the area where i was raised and
my family has always been uh critical of
the government there is not a single
person in my immediate uh circles that
are fans of this government okay but i
would say that just from my own personal
experience just looking at cars or
driving or parking anywhere i don't see
a single z
sign there is no single i would say
personal initiative to install anything
that is commemorative to this war
all i've seen is state council local
efforts which are sponsored from the
state from the federal budget to try and
convince people to engage in such
practices and some type of coercion
that's happening for example in
kindergarten oftentimes parents discover
that the school trip or the kindergarten
trip they send their children to was
actually a sort of patriotic uh event
because they then later find pictures of
the children posed in the letter z on
social media or that's the patriotic
education trump keeps talking about now
listen do you feel safe expressing your
views antagonistic to the government
on here yes uh over at my university
i've already sort of spoken myself into
15 years of prison if anybody would like
deep dig anywhere around me
so um this is just a weird stasis that i
know that if anybody looked at me or
what i have been writing what i've been
saying it is quite possible that i will
face some sort of fine or maybe even
jail time after all a person was
arrested yesterday for working out with
a printout of russian constitution onto
the streets
[Music]
and there are
unfortunately i'm also you know like a
liberal i'm a college professor so if
any of my students decide that they
don't like me they can
write a letter to celeste committed
which is like a prosecutor's office of
russia and i will be gone so
but on the other hand unfortunately my
family has had this same experience
since 1930s so it's not like we're
inexperienced in this particular
situation sure so sure
it's just weird and uh i don't like it
well stay safe snake and um how how
upset were you by the closure of
mcdonald's in russia
actually there is a lot of work in
mcdonald's spots like i
yeah i visited kazan which is a city in
tatarstan a republic within russia and
they have plenty working mcdonald's i
think all of the mcdonald's is located
at airports are working as well wow i
think franchisees are still open while
those that were commanded by u.s
headquarters so they have all closed i
see i see all right well snake thank you
for the call and stay safe there
thank you all right there is snake from
moscow and that will do it for today
we'll take a quick break we will take
calls again
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
let's get into this week's email bag you
can email info davidpakman.com if you
have a question comment suggestion
correction
whatever really it's all welcome as long
as it's respectful let's get right into
the first one
linda wrote in about something i said
about the noah's ark story last week
last week i said you know one i struggle
with some of these stories and fail to
get answers when i say well
uh if there were two of every
uh two of every animal um you had every
kind of bird and every kind of insect
and you know we're talking about
millions of species how is that possible
or what did the carnivorous animals eat
whatever right
and linda wrote in and said actually
linda and or john
it says both names and they say
according to genesis 1 29
man kind and animals were originally
vegetarians
the food was put in the arc per 622
and in 9 1-5 after they landed god
instituted a new covenant and the eating
of meat this is the type of thing that
i'm kind of um
talking about because there's always
some explanation but it doesn't actually
make any scientific sense so like for
example in this case it's well the
animals were vegetarian at the time of
noah's ark
and then the animals started to eat meat
others will say well actually really
god's will and direction
really only applies to humans not to
animals so now now god is directing what
animals eat
the other counterpoint would be
well if this all happened in the last
five or six thousand years
there is number one no evidence that
currently carnivorous animals were ever
vegetarian and if the idea is they
evolved from being vegetarian to being
carnivorous
5 000 years is not nearly enough time
for that to happen to all of those
species so that also doesn't make sense
but i get that they don't believe in the
evolution piece anyway so it it all
doesn't make sense another email said
well on noah's ark they were eating
pickled and dried meats the carnivorous
animals ate pickled and dried meats and
that's why
um
the car the issue of
the animals that were alive being eaten
isn't an issue well but there's no
evidence of that another one was they
were all eating fish eggs i've not seen
any evidence of that
the other one i got was david there were
two of each main species so like there
were just two snakes
and then later those two snakes became
all the subspecies
maybe that would be plausible if we were
talking about millions of years or
longer but if this all supposedly
happened in five or six thousand years
that doesn't make any sense so the point
here is they'll always come up with
something
um but there's no evidence for any of
the stuff and at a certain point you
have to say well what do i accept as
evidence and i've still not seen any
uh convincing explanation of the noah's
ark story okay next is michael michael
wrote in about people who don't talk
politics michael says there's people on
the right and left but mainly the right
who simply don't talk politics is there
a way to convince them why they need to
get out and vote these radical
conservatives out i think many of them
are republicans because it's passed down
so yes there's lots of people that are
republicans because they come from a
republican family in my experience the
best way to get people who aren't into
politics to follow politics is to say to
them okay i get it you just you don't
care about politics you don't care about
news it's boring and you're just not
interested i totally get that that makes
sense there's so many things that that
what we can pay attention to tell me
what matters to you
they go well i don't know i like sports
and uh car driving or whatever else you
go no i understand that but you must
think there's some problems in the world
either in your immediate community or
with government or with
there must be some problem they go well
yeah i mean i really hated that
whatever right something related to
climate or something related to a law of
legislation regulation of their business
you go well you might not care about
politics but other people then are
deciding
how your business is regulated other
people are deciding how your immediate
parks that are around you are being
taken care of or not taken care of so
the point here is
people who aren't into politics
usually still have opinions about the
world around them and it's about just
explaining to them that it's the
political system that will impact what
happens and that that will often work to
get people to say oh i didn't realize
that
this thing i care about actually is
politics and i should be paying
attention and i should be involved give
it a shot let me know how it works
ozan wrote in saying about clarence
thomas
david sir whatever happened to the ginny
thomas story the media seems to have
lost interest in it if this were a more
liberal judge in a similar situation
it's easy for me to see the mainstream
media and fox mentioning the story
constantly for days on end i would love
to hear your thoughts
uh on another note i've been a member
over a year now and love what you do
you're doing a great job keep it up
thank you
so we have a situation where like every
week there's a pretty major scandal
during the trump presidency it was
basically every other day but now every
week or every couple of weeks there's
some big story we found out to find out
something crazy that mark meadows did or
jenny thomas did or whatever jenny
thomas was quite uh involved as a
supporter of the january sixth
festivities and um
the story has basically gone away and i
think it's just an information overload
type of thing it's two things right-wing
media won't even talk about it
and then in addition even we on the left
and independent media we also have so
many things to talk about that we can't
keep every story in the forefront all
the time that's why it's good to have
lots of independent media outlets some
that specialize on legal stories some
that specialize in whatever but you're
completely right the story is kind of
gone and it may be gone forever
last week i asked about who's more
dangerous in a cult and the cult is
trumpism
the true believers or the false
believers who go yeah yeah the election
was stolen but they don't really believe
it but they say it to be part of the
team
silver wrote in
and said david i believe the false
believers are worse it's similar to my
understanding of the difference between
a drug addict and a narcissist in other
words the drug addict displays
narcissistic behavior but is either
unaware or does so to get a fix
the narcissist likewise knows their
manipulate manipulative behavior pattern
but they don't care
it is definitely a difficult question
but i believe of the two that the one
who knows their actions could possibly
be the worst of the two
uh is is the worst one so if i
understand correctly what silver is
saying is
the false believers
don't even believe this stuff
but still repeat it knowing that its
effect could be destructive and that
thus they are worse whereas the true
believer in the case of the big lie
thinks no the election was really stolen
so that's something we have to fix and
therefore they are less pernicious
i could be convinced of that
there's definite there's definitely some
logic to that yeah now that that makes
some sense
canadian paul wrote in about the
republican recently suggesting fauci be
killed
by firing squad
writing in stochastic fouchy firing
squad sir
i would like to add another
consideration to your coverage of the
uh
p-u-y-a-s-o
i don't know what that acronym is john
bennett and his suggestion that dr fauci
should face a firing squad i believe
this to be the least common form of
execution today but it was used quite
intentionally of the 74 million
republican trump voters how many have a
gas chamber in their basement an
electric chair in their living room or
the chemistry background to administer a
lethal injection
now
how many have a gun
keep up the great work i think the point
that canadian paul is talking about here
is
if you want to get fouchy killed
and you go
fauci should be sent to the electric
chair
most trumpists don't have an electric
chair in their basement maybe some do
but most don't they don't have the means
to do the thing that's being suggested
but
uh many trumpists have a gun
and that's why he said firing squad that
canadian paul may be on to something it
may not have been an accident that the
term firing squad was used
steve wrote in about the pandemic and
steve says do you really think states
are honestly reporting covet cases i
don't for one second think the reports
are honest from all states not even
close so the the answer is no
but there's two parts to this one are
there states that are deliberately
hiding coveted cases at this point maybe
i mean listen probably there's 50 states
there's you could probably find an
example of some official somewhere who
is uh limiting
the higher numbers from being published
it's probably true the bigger issue is
now a lot of people who have symptoms
don't even get tested so they just don't
show up in the numbers and a lot of
people who do a home test and test
positive never report it and so of
course the numbers are lower
in i'm still hearing some reports that
say the real case numbers are 2
to three times higher than what is being
reported but it's not necessarily
because the numbers are being lied about
it's people are testing at home or not
testing and none of that ever makes it
into the case numbers
next email is about
uh dan bongino and my pronunciation
dan bongino you disappointed me
hi david i love your show keep up the
great work started watching your show a
few months ago because you're fair and
you explain things with data
you disappointed me when you pronounce
dan bongino's name incorrectly the i
is pronounced as a long e and not an i
bongino
i only bring this up because you go on
all the people that pronounced the new
supreme court nominee's name incorrectly
which is great and i agree with you 100
to paraphraser you said something like
come on guys get the name right
you actually said maybe they're doing it
on purpose maybe they don't know how to
pronounce it you did the exact same
thing with dan bongino so david were you
making fun of dan's name
or did you really not know how to
pronounce it i'm sure a lot in the
audience as i do await your answer keep
up the great work
what do you guys think do you guys think
i know
it's not pronounced bongino
do you think i know it's not pronounced
tulsi gabbard
you think i know it's not pronounced
jimmy dore
let me know
let me know i think uh the answer will
become very evident
philip wrote in a quick correction and
this i love this i love being corrected
on this stuff we talked about the
betting odds for candidates you can go
on the website predict it
and you can bet monies
who will be the republican nominee you
can bet on anything you want and philip
wrote in and said david you described it
as 70 cents of every dollar bet to
describe the process of betting using
the predicted prediction markets in
reality
the prices are the cost of a contract
that settles at either a dollar or
nothing not the amount of every dollar
bet on that market it's the cost of a
contract not the volume might be
pedantic but i know david values
accuracy no i appreciate that when you
go on to predict it it'll say for
example
70 cents next to donald trump i wrongly
said that means 70 cents
70
of the dollars bet are being bet on
trump being the nominee that's wrong
uh but i think if i understand correctly
you have to bet 70 cents
to end up making a dollar because it's
relatively likely that it will be trump
whereas on a long shot candidate you
might only have to bet five cents to
make a dollar if you're right i think
that that's the correct way i'm not a
big betting guy but i appreciate the
correction okay lastly and guys this is
just an instructive thing on things i
can't do
sunday night owen wrote to me
and said hey david
i'm late on a part that's due for my
paper it's a persuasive essay we could
choose any topic so i chose why
corporate money should be taken out of
politics i need counter arguments to
that point i was wondering if you knew
any to make it easier on me guys i can't
help you with your homework okay
you would be surprised at how often i
get stuff like this you gotta do your
own work i can't number one this was due
the next day
um
you know
even if you thought i could help you
with your homework if you email me
sunday night for monday homework i
obviously can't help you
number two i don't have the ability or
where with all and resources to respond
to the emails that i get and number
three do your own work owen please this
is a very important life lesson do your
own work i'm begging you all right we
have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpacman.com you'll get
instant access it'll be a beautiful
thing you can use the coupon code
obama remember that obama
yeah you can use that as a coupon code
to get a discount when you sign up and
we'll see you on the bonus check